doing the Dirty Work
filling up the PB
[Laughter]
s
[Music]
and welcome back everybody to another
amazing episode of be careful boys and
today we have Kristen back in the sea
but more importantly welcome back Joe
yeah
what's up Joe [ __ ] boss is back I
mean you're important too but but more
importantly but then but then but then I
remember when you posted on um Instagram
Ryan that video of her roasting us I was
like oh wouldn't that burn hurt but it's
so good and then I was like I gotta
promote this and show that uh she
single-handedly brought us back to life
because of her Tick Tock following right
no but it kind of worked I was like you
guys don't get any views and then the
next day it's just yes
thank you 100 rise one view thanks for
the view and everyone was like see I
told you you needed girls back on JK
it's all because of girls
yeah we gotta get more girls back on
though you know we missed you Joe thanks
man I missed you guys too it's been a
it's been weird because I think that was
the first break I've had since covid
like this I never missed JK oh we're two
years straight or something how has life
been over there and what do you miss
about here
I miss
the weather here what really really the
weather is [ __ ] hot all the time oh
and I missed all of us like wait people
who like Hawaii because the weather
that's Paradise right yeah I don't have
AC in my house oh it's like a hot box
and I'm on the second floor because it
feels it feels like someone's going like
hey like what do you miss about Earth
and they're in heaven and like the AC is
too good there's no AC I want to go back
to Earth and you're like what I think
everything else is amazing yeah
everything else is amazing now obviously
like I like to I like to have JK news
but the biggest problem is there's no AC
but it works for all of us because we
all want AC so bad that we wake up extra
early to go to the office and get work
done because the office has 24 7 Ac uh
sweet yeah so it feels like a luxury and
then don't they have portable AC
machines it's like it's like the future
I told everyone I'm like I'm not getting
one for myself and you guys can't get
one either because we don't deserve it
isn't that kind of tyrannical to like
and I said we need to feel this
suffering you need to complain about the
Heat and you need to open up the shop
and until the shop is open we're not
getting any luxury so you really want
like the Sweatshop Vibe huh nice a
literal switch up so you're making sure
that where you live and all the people
that you work with live there yep so
it's so [ __ ] hot it's that they clock
in early to work hard exactly that's
pretty smart hey we have AC
is gonna like backfire in the future or
something like that nope because they're
family and you can't you can't run away
you're right so evil so right now I got
this thing where it's uh you know Hannah
and my nephews are running the shop and
you know every you know like when you
got family run in the shop
um indentured servitude Free Labor baby
you know what I mean that's right that's
right
yeah it's horrible and then the laws
don't you know they don't apply because
they're doing 14-hour shifts so let's go
yeah that's sweet it's pretty effective
they're clocking in doesn't start when
they go into the shop it starts when
they wake up in the morning damn
yeah it's been pretty fun no for real
though it's always been a dream of mine
to have a family business like to build
something together that's like because
all the free labor because one free
labor Free Labor is amazing
you know every business wishes they had
free labor that's why they try to
automate with robots and stuff but
Asians have been doing it it's called
family labor that's the same as robots
yeah they just gotta do it and like I
wish from a young age my nephews were uh
like like child labor because then it
would be really cool what do you mean
like child labor
um they're in their 20s now so they're
adults so you'd like them to be younger
I could also it's just regular labor
it's not child labor but I could have no
no I could have had them
like as children working for me yeah but
their parents wanted them to go to
school makes sense got in the way so it
did get in the way damn you good parents
15 years of them like running around
here working for us
they had to go to school don't you have
to like feed them and stuff do you feed
them jumbee every day yeah but when
they're small they're you know and they
don't need that much yeah they're not
that they're skinny like especially when
they're little they don't like to eat
little kids don't like to eat I'm sure
Tai could only it's it's tough to get
them to eat food right yeah like we
don't even need to order a third dish
really exactly and tons of energy Free
Labor yup Free Labor yeah you got to get
on that cook before he starts going to
school and [ __ ]
I actually thought about that like
there's all these like creators now
right where it's like Mom and kid or dad
and kid and then the kids like I don't
know like four five six seven eight and
I'm like if the point of going to school
is to get a job but if you already have
a job and like let's say you and your
dad or you and your mom I love where
this is going I'm a following that's
like I don't know 10 million or some
[ __ ] yeah and those fools are making
bank like Ryan's world yeah why do you
need to go to school if you're working
now so would that mean school's useless
for a kid like that or do you guys think
like general education and learning
about Christopher Columbus that's a
tough question because it depends on the
schooling like if my kid had like the
Privileges that taika had going to like
a school that you picked and you can
afford and stuff yeah I don't know maybe
he would go to school but like us
regular people us like you know down to
earth like you know generic Public
School people I don't know man that's
not really good schooling you know so
that's true I would go with the 10
million following Ryan's World whatever
the [ __ ] he just said pull them out of
school [ __ ] the public school Loki like
the public school I do you think it's
kind of like whatever like when you talk
about like those uh private schools that
are like these people actually it's like
one one staff member for every two
children or some [ __ ] they actually have
attention and stuff I'm like
wait so that's like real learning yeah
you know what I'm saying versus
babysitting a room full of like 30
degenerates and you're hoping like 16 of
them don't pull red cards today which
[ __ ] disciplines you for what you
know what I'm saying if you live in like
OC in some like San Clemente town like
yeah stay in school it's probably really
fun yeah but if you go to school with a
bunch of kids they're always like hey
let me get some money bro like you can
kill it like that real OC
I think that the school system is
changing though um there's been a huge
study that um College
um attendance rates are dropping a ton I
feel like people are catching on I mean
I didn't go to school but I feel like
people are catching on they're like this
shit's expensive [ __ ] I still don't have
a job after four years and I'm broke so
and the job you get isn't necessarily
connected to people and if you've got
student loans come on or if you're a
student you're a student that went to
school and I'm gonna work for my uncle
anyways
for free they're like why did I even go
to there's lots of shots did any of you
guys have student loans
oh I mean yeah paid them off but it was
a lot dude well done but no actually I
didn't have student loans I had debt
incurred because I didn't work during
school so like I had credit card like
debt and all this like 30 grand worth
from expenses yeah because I was just
like damn you like a grown ass adult in
school I know it's not school loans it's
credit card debt there's a difference
you got some hair on your chest man yeah
that was that was uh that was a
interesting life okay so keep telling us
about Jimmy so where's it at now are
they still working while you're over
here like having fun with us we just
opened Sunday but it was a secret I
didn't it's called the soft open when
you do it can't wait for a hard one you
know so you don't flip the sign all the
way around for opening you just kind of
put it right in the middle people have
to look at it
so are there a hell of people coming in
already like just yeah the food
traffic's crazy so I knew that I knew
that that's why I was like and David was
like don't make the same mistake I did
with drips where the day that it opened
we blasted it out and then all the
employees were like like they're like we
didn't even practice for this [ __ ] yet
and then it freaked them out right right
right right and then everyone that's
opened up a business in Waikiki told me
the same thing don't do it like on a
crazy weekend don't do it like um you
know because a lot of people will just
don't overwhelm yourself because they'll
be like this is what it's gonna be like
[ __ ] that right so then what we did was
we over staffed we made sure like we're
not even open for the full hours and
then I was like all right let me like
ease people into this because I want
them to be really sick so that by the
time not like sick like you know what I
mean but I'm trying to be cool I want
them to be like hip-hop sick
I have no context by the way of what
this
is actually try to guess you see a juice
Bigelow male gigolo huh okay continue we
should try to make her guess to see like
what kind of business just keep just
keep going it's a drink shop it's matcha
based drink shop we have Boba we have
all kinds of stuff
yay I wanted to be on the nose
an even more fun game
yeah uh oh yeah yeah so they told me all
this stuff they said like a lot of
people do quit when it gets too crazy
for the first date because it's scary
you can't go [ __ ]
when they walk out no no you can't and
also we were understaffed I needed about
30 something people I thought you just
said you overstaffed oh for the shift uh
yeah so then I need 30 something people
I couldn't even open for the same hours
I want to open for from seven to nine
right now we're only open from 11 to 8.
yeah so
um yeah I wanted them to be trained so
then after the Grand Opening by the time
this video is out it's probably like
fully ready to go you guys could go
check it out
I wanted them to be able to pump out a
drink in less than a minute in other
shops around Waikiki dude like sometimes
it'll take you 15 minutes to get a
coffee
complicated drink no dude like we do
we've done a lot of like
like competitive research right I would
go into some shops and their workers are
just talking like this and they don't
even recognize that people are standing
and waiting and then you'll be like
[ __ ] workers hi and I'm like dude
that's [ __ ] up [ __ ] Hawaiians
and most of them aren't even from Hawaii
dude they give Hawaii a badass rep
[ __ ] tourists
[ __ ] immigrants [ __ ] house
transplants go back to your country say
it yeah say it all right
[ __ ] How the Grinch yeah so so I was
like that's a problem and I don't want
our team to be like that because if
people are traveling right you're
probably in a rush trying to get your
caffeine for a day so you could like go
down to your checklist of I'm gonna go
snorkeling and this and that and then
people are just standing and waiting and
[ __ ] and there's so many different
places and coffee shops or like and and
drink shops that are like this where you
go in and it takes like eight minutes
things are slow bro and I was like I
don't want that to happen for our group
you guys are like the F1 of drinks out
there I want to that's why I want to be
quick setting the standard and it's
crazy man like it's just uh to me I had
culture shock when I was like hiring
folks like I would say like
um
maybe more than half didn't show up to
the interview
people told me too they're like hey
people will will just bounce I'm like
what are you talking about like
everybody
in the middle of their shift dude in the
middle of their [ __ ] people will go to
the bathroom and they would bounce or
like they would they would all like I
was like what are you talking about like
yeah I had a manager at my shop go to
the bathroom the manager the manager and
never come back and I was like this is
the island you know like you you can't
just run away and hide
they're like and then like lateness is a
problem like or like just bailing and
not showing up to work and then coming
back the next day like there's they
still got a job like all this stuff so
I'm like that does sound very Hawaiian
though these are really funny because I
think to them it doesn't even feel like
it's like a character flaw it's just a
vibe that they have
that's the power of the things Jeremiah
in Hawaii and uh I was like hey I DM
them like hey I want I need a train can
I come by your gym he goes yeah and then
um he comes by he opens up the gym
they're supposed to open at 11 but they
open at eight for me and I go train and
then he was like all right I'll see you
later he just leaves up there
wait you're just gonna leave me here and
then he has expensive ass equipment in
La I would never leave anyone else
anyways walk up he's like I'll come back
at like noon or something and then I was
like oh I'm gonna be gone before they go
oh no that's okay bro and I'm like
that's tight all right so I just think
it's just that chill that goes both ways
it's laid back yeah like you could fire
me I can quit whatever yeah whatever you
want man letting you lock up for the gym
and keep in the June B restaurant just
like chilling by itself feel different
bouncing but there's like thousands of
dollars and he could hurt himself or
like just lie like like he has TVs and
[ __ ] in there it's like a gym you know
like there's [ __ ] like expensive ass
[ __ ] like the whole place is probably
worth half a million and you could
people could just come and just take all
that [ __ ] and he didn't even give a [ __ ]
I had to fire a kid before I even hired
him
so all right
right it sounds crazy right
congrats you're fine I know thanks for
showing up and now he's getting
unemployment
no he did a great job on an interview I
really liked them I wanted him to you
know start working with us and then um
for some reason like he wouldn't read
his [ __ ] email so I had to text him
and I'll be like hey man no like
um uh you got to check your email and he
goes oh I read it I read it and then I
was like well you got to respond to it
man and and let us know that you're
you're gonna accept this job if you're
down and he's like oh yeah yeah yeah
okay okay so he he sent a response he
just didn't know the email etiquette
she read it and he was like Yay I got
the job and he didn't respond back when
he showed up first day but then he still
needed to sign up like you know for the
for the Gusto payments he needed to send
in his ID and all these things right so
then after 10 days I was like hey man
like I can't I can't like Be the One
chasing after you for this job yeah and
then um he's just on his break man yeah
yeah yeah no he just ghosted me so I
just texted him I said hey man like I um
you know um I gotta Reef I gotta fill
this position up like I don't have any
response from you there's no
communication like I don't know what's
going on
um and I was like good luck you know but
like yeah that was it was just a weird
experience because I was like I never
well at least for me even like when I
first started working and stuff if I
wanted a job and I got a interview I'm
like yeah and I didn't balance I didn't
you know if I need to reschedule I did
that like I didn't just bail but a lot
of folks would like either bail know
just don't even show up at all or like
last minute like 30 minutes before the
interview try to reschedule and I'm like
what the [ __ ] is happening you have
another time slot for this interview
yeah and it was it was like a ton dude
I'm not I'm like not even kidding you
it's like half and I didn't I probably
went through like at least 60. so that
makes sense why it takes like 30 minutes
to make a drink then because they might
they might have quit and then came back
and quit again and then we're gonna
applied I'll guess I'll make it so I
have a quick story
um I'm gonna expose myself right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
this is a good one
um so I it was a while back I got a job
at an acai Place smoothie is kind of
same thing you know I need some extra
money
um started working there
um I never officially got hired before I
got fired
um it's coming so
I'm working there I'm training I'm a
very very hard worker you know I'm
loving it I'm chopping the fruits I'm
making the smoothies like you said one
minute boom here's your smoothie here's
your bowl I'm killing it my friend works
at this job as well so
um she's the one who got me the job it
was our first day working together I'm
like okay we have to you know be
professional there's no managers there
at all um so there's just oh your first
thing yeah so there's just the person
training me and my friend there and
they're teaching me how to refill the
peanut butter
um so the manager and my friend who have
worked there that are training me
they're like this is how you do it you
put on the gloves you scoop the peanut
butter you put it in the bucket it's
really really fun and I'm like cool so I
put on the gloves and I'm like playing
with this peanut butter my friend
records me and puts me on our Instagram
story and apparently that's not the way
that you're supposed to do it but that's
how they trained me to do it and then
management saw her story and I got fired
because I'm the peanut butter girl so
now I I never got hired from it and now
I'm such a good worker but now every
time someone quits there's this Legacy I
left behind people take a video of them
scooping the peanut butter with their
pandas and they like throw it in the
bucket and they leave and it's still
good
oh what the [ __ ] can we pull up a video
of this do you have this what's the
what's the correct my imagination is
running wild
I'll send it and it'll be like a
congratulations game I want to go there
in like 10 years and be like hey you
still doing the peanut butter thing yeah
was it because like corporate saw that
yeah like the corporate was yeah but
they trained me like that apparently
you're like there were scoopers what's
the name of this establishment am I
supposed to blast that what does it
rhyme with find anything that said
you're not allowed to riozonas Rio zones
I've never heard of that so then all we
got to do is go there and when you get
your peanut butter drink no I wanted
hand scooped man you guys said you guys
do it
put the peanut butter gloves on get to
work do the Kristen you know the Kristen
from corporate
yeah that's [ __ ] crazy yeah that just
sounds so fun though they really just
taught you to do it one way they put you
online what's the right way isn't there
like our scoopers but the people that
own the business they're from Brazil you
know they speak like Portuguese and
stuff so this lady came in and she
starts like yelling at me in a different
language and like you should understand
yeah and then she pulls up the video and
I was like oh that's not me I was like
that's my friend like I'm trying to put
it on her but yeah
um I never got hired and then my friend
quit the next week so I just realized
you know regular work isn't for me I
didn't really want the job anyway thank
you
but you know what that's one of the
biggest issues about like in like
working is that you have shitty managers
you have shitty trainers and then like
you have shitty owners that don't really
listen or like figure [ __ ] out and then
they just blame you yeah what the [ __ ]
was that little
went viral and
[ __ ] and they would have came for the
peanut butter girl so they just don't
know business they don't know and that's
why nobody's ever heard of their shop I
don't even know what that is but I'm
pretty sure a lot of people heard of
jumbee though
[Music]
foreign